y la laparoscopia pélvica diagnóstica se
utiliza para examinar los órganos
internos de la pelvis con el fin de
identificar un problema específico
puede que se le recomiende someterse a
una laparoscopia pélvica diagnósticas si
tiene dolor pélvico una masa acumulación
anormal de líquidos o dificultad para
quedar embarazada
y esto se puede deber a endometriosis
embarazo tubárica tumor o quiste de
ovario escarificación debido a
infecciones pélvicas u otras afecciones
las técnicas laparoscópicas requieren
solo una incisión mínima en forma de ojo
de cerradura o una incisión punzante y
el periodo de recuperación es más corto
y menos doloroso cuando llega al
hospital para el procedimiento se le
colocará una vía intravenosa y es
posible que se le suministre un sedante
para ayudarle a relajarse la
laparoscopia pélvica se realiza con
anestesia general por lo tanto estará
dormida durante el tiempo que dure la
operación se insertará temporalmente un
tubo respiratorio por la boca y en la
garganta para ayudarle a respirar
durante la operación además se le
colocará un catéter en la vejiga para
drenar la orina
una laparoscopia diagnóstica sin
complicaciones puede tardar entre 30 y
60 minutos
el cirujano podrá acceder al interior de
la pelvis mediante el uso de
instrumentos cortantes denominados
trócares con los que realizará una
abertura pequeña o puerto de entrada de
media pulgada debajo del ombligo
luego se bombeará dióxido de carbono a
través del puerto de entrada umbilical
para inflar el abdomen y así poder
visualizar su contenido más fácilmente a
continuación el cirujano insertará el
laparoscopio a través del puerto
umbilical las imágenes de la cámara se
proyectan en un monitor de la sala de
operaciones
el cirujano examinará cuidadosamente los
tejidos y órganos pélvicos en busca de
signos de enfermedad que pudieran
explicar sus síntomas puede crear otros
puertos a través de los cuales se pueden
deslizar instrumentos estos instrumentos
adicionales se utilizan para desplazar
órganos para visualizar mejor o para
realizar procedimientos operativos tales
como extirpar tejido fibroso realizar
biopsias muestras de tejidos o drenar
fluido anormal cuando el laparoscopio y
los demás instrumentos se retiran se
deja en el lugar una válvula de gas
especial por poco tiempo para liberar
todo el dióxido de carbono del abdomen
las incisiones en forma de ojo de
cerraduras se cierran con algunas
suturas o grapas y luego se cubren con
un vendaje
después de la cirugía se le retirará el
tubo respiratorio y se la monitorear a
en el área de recuperación poco rato
después se le retirará el catéter y se
le administrarán medicamentos para el
dolor según sea necesario cuando pueda
tomar líquidos se le retirará la vía
intravenosa la mayoría de las pacientes
son dadas de alta pocas horas después
del procedimiento